greed
fear and pride it's a trifecta and I
have done all three uh and all three
will make you broke
see pride is I buy a car to impress
someone at a stoplight that I will never
meet would I buy this if no one ever saw
it oh yeah that's your test on the pride
button right greed is I'm just Money
Motivated to the exclusion of other
things that are healthy
you can have a money motivation and not
and not be excluded to the exclusion of
other things but if you're only if
you're only button to push is money
that's great and the third one I love
you said is desperate that's the worst
one when you get desperate just about 20
seconds later after I get desperate I
get stupid and right after I get stupid
I get broke right I mean it's true it's
an aggressive causal thing it desperate
leads to stupid leads to broke